boulay cab show special guest in here
spiffy Luciano no you know welcome
thanks for having me welcome my man
appreciate it good to see you've been
making some [ __ ] noise
congratulations yeah the new situation
with my man Boosie yeah my dog big dog I
always tell people that uh you know when
you meet certain celebrities usually
they disappoint you except for if you
meet boozy you ain't gonna disappoint
you he's exactly who you [ __ ] see
online that's exactly
yeah for sure don't play with them so
originally you bought a feature from him
right right and so he just [ __ ] with
it so much and [ __ ] with y'all like
was it like did you buy the feature in
the video or like how did it about the
feature and the video but
it that was four years ago it was a long
time ago it was a long time ago like so
he he's he must have was thinking just
waiting watching me work let me see what
he gonna do paying attention paid
attention and came and got me like wow
what the hood yeah that's crazy what if
you don't mind me asking what was the
what was the bag for the feature and the
video four years ago
this 15. that's not bad no I ain't bad
that's not bad at all it was good it was
a good investment for me of course four
years later I'm [ __ ] with the biggest
yeah I'm cool with that and like I think
too like Boosie's got like a very like a
underrated track record when it comes to
like signing artists because a lot of
people like young blue you know what I'm
saying that's he's the guy who believed
in blue first exactly 100 man what part
of me what part of L.A are you from
Crenshaw District South Central yeah
um for you because I know you've been
back and forth between Atlanta and LA
do you feel like the difference in like
because I go to Atlanta and it feels
like a whole different [ __ ] it just
feels like especially during the
pandemic right they never closed so the
[ __ ] is like it's lit all day yeah how
do you like the like you know the
contrast of being in Atlanta a lot now
compared to being out no like obviously
being home
I'm away from distractions yeah people
can't tell me to just pull up I don't
really know nobody in Atlanta like that
I only only [ __ ] with Boosie so when I'm
not [ __ ] with him I'm in my own world
just rapping rapping my ass off I can't
go see nobody I can't go just pull up or
you can't pull up on me and be
distracting me like I'm here just I'm
working you know so it's more like a
work thing it's my job [ __ ] it is your
job yeah how long have you actually been
like taking the rap [ __ ] serious how
many years has it been since I really
came out the wound I can't count the
years because I really
just been doing this [ __ ] right for as
long as I can remember do you remember
like uh when you first realized you you
could make some money off the rap rap
game because a lot of people they do it
but then they don't really when I turn
like 15 16 yeah start realizing more
but not really knowing everything but I
knew I could do something like this [ __ ]
real right like it could happen for you
so I just kept doing it right growing up
in that area
um
obviously you know Nipsey being
a legend coming up from your same
section
um was that like uh
did you did you grab a lot of
inspiration from someone like Nick from
those guys yeah [ __ ] mainly Nick yeah
that's where all the inspiration really
came from
growing up and watching him watching
Boosie
but I was able to watch nips up close
because I was around like when around
him all the time but I was around to see
it around the Watchers grind watch what
he did try to follow the steps the best
way I could but in my own way so
he was a big part of my inspiration yeah
yeah what up we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family over at my bookie that's
right with lots going on in basketball
right now Lots going on in the NFL
playoffs are about to start Super Bowls
coming up so much to gamble on let's win
some money go to my bookie right now if
you sign up for a new account
mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview
yeah and also it's I always tell people
this that they will never understand it
but like living here
I feel like somehow
Nipsey dying was a bigger loss to La
than Kobe and that's a crazy thing to
say for people who don't live here right
but like
being like being here for both of those
you know you know just Monumental losses
to the city
I just felt like the nipsy death hit
harder man
[ __ ] hit harder than any death really
yeah any like that he he hit us hard
I mean even just like uh him passing
like I know it was temporary but like
the fact like biggie was able to have
everybody pull up over there that
usually be around each other legendary
[ __ ] yeah
that's a pretty uh it's pretty crazy uh
you know to think back like his memory
and the respect that he had amongst
people even on that side like
you know was strong enough to have
everyone and their mom in the same spot
at the same time yeah that was dope yeah
not too many people could pull [ __ ] off
like that 100 100
um for you do you feel like
I feel like sometimes and I feel like
it's been less and less more recent
um
because some of the younger artists they
might be from certain areas but they're
not necessarily banging
but do you feel like um
sometimes the politics of maybe where
you're from gets in the way of like
Cali
being bigger than what it is in terms of
the hip-hop scene because because like
we think back to like you know nipsey's
era there was artists he never worked
with you know what I mean he never did
his own Schoolboy Q There was like
records that like [ __ ] never happened
just because of like certain politics
not necessarily like there was any
issues but do you feel like that's still
a thing
yeah
that's still a thing
and then in Atlanta you go out there and
it feels like everybody's just kind of
everybody [ __ ] with each other
everyone's [ __ ] with each other on
some positive shame ain't nobody
no none of that everybody just everybody
getting together doing songs with each
other trying to up each other yeah you
know it's different you know
yeah I think a lot of uh that's
something that Kailyn did that I thought
was dope was like when Kailyn started to
pop he went to the South he like went to
Atlanta for like he went to Atlanta yeah
and like Atlanta he popped he was like
hanging out in Atlanta in Florida and
like doing the things that were like
kind of necessary to get out of because
you know we always see a bunch of dope
La Legends but sometimes the ceiling is
like
so high it's only so high out here it's
so high you could go it's like you got
to go tap in and other like you know
we've got to go to a minute or not
Atlanta is the biggest city for hip-hop
in the last I mean Freddie they've been
holding it down for 20 years now you
know what I'm saying so I think that's
dope that you were able to do that what
was it um
for you was there like any question when
boozy offered you the deal were you like
I'm in you know or or
there was no question yeah I was in it's
[ __ ] you were talking about
well you know because boozy is obviously
I lived in Florida for a long time so I
was able to kind of see like boozy's
like like when he would call himself
like
when he would compare himself to Tupac
I've seen what he means to certain
people yeah so I get it he is like the
Tupac of the South yes for sure for sure
and but but a lot of people don't unless
you've lived there and you've seen like
the reaction he gets in certain places
they won't understand it all right so
for you were you able to kind of like
when you were growing up was boozy and
Webbie and those guys like heavily like
in your rotation where were they like a
part of your Boosie
Webby Nick the hot boys Lil Wayne Like
[ __ ] but it was just mainly Boosie we
learned at the gangsters like we was
into that type of [ __ ] growing up so
it was mainly Boosie
that's crazy being in L.A yeah yeah
that's that's a shout out to [ __ ] man
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah Bluetooth gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you got to do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're going to get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring it to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not going to perform
it's not it's not going to perform how
you'd like it to but you know how it
will perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview for you
2023 is gonna be a big year for you man
um
all right a lot of plan I plan to take
my little juice uh not little my big
Juice company I got
I do Exotic juices for artists like you
know not you know like how exotic pop
got going with the artists but I just
mainly like do the upcoming [ __ ] or
like [ __ ] that they don't touch like I
can't touch them like come on
let's get your juices going and I do it
and my [ __ ] dope so you have a juice
company a juice lemon baby juice so like
what are what are some of the flavors
you have right now
[ __ ] out of the I got Boosie juice
I Got No Cap [ __ ] oh [ __ ] uh I got I got
a little meat [ __ ]
uh I I got Young Thug [ __ ] free thug
that copy Supreme [ __ ]
what's the name of your juice and my
[ __ ] slime baby juice oh that's a big
deal man this is a big artist yeah
what's the best selling flavor right now
the best one
[ __ ] if that's one of mine yours yeah
how do they get the juice oh good yeah
I'm getting it going right now but yep
you're gonna be able to purchase it
online or hit me personally get cases
from me yeah like all type of [ __ ] like
that that's dope I'm gonna take it for
uh music wise what do you got coming uh
album in January like the top of January
so the album's already done yeah it's
done about the top of January is like a
week away yeah that's like a week away
like like probably when it's like two
weeks in when the quarters start
top of January you got you're definitely
gonna have the CEO on the album I'm
assuming most definitely yeah like
probably like on two three songs where
do you see yourself fitting into like
um the LA landscape of like the new
generation these days because it is a
very thriving scene right now I feel
like I feel like La hip-hop is in good
hands right now in terms of the Next
Generation
like as far as fitting in
I don't know I ain't never really fit in
yeah I feel like you do have a very oh
it stood up you do have a sound that
stands out amongst what's going on in LA
right now yeah your style
is not necessarily Regional if that
makes sense right because a lot of uh
you know a lot of La [ __ ] is like it
sounds like some Malaysia some L.A [ __ ]
yeah whatever they say that sound is
yeah
my [ __ ] on some whole other [ __ ] like
yeah like the freestyle you did uh was
it the 50 Cent freestyle where there was
like a 21 Questions yellow bone in the
video that yeah
fat [ __ ]
shout out to her yeah shout out to her
oh man that [ __ ] was hard though
like it's it's crazy too because like I
feel like we don't get enough of those
kind of freestyles anymore we're back
when I was growing up that was all we
heard was [ __ ] flipping other
people's [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
heart Dean that's right hard Dean Las
Vegas the craziest dispensary in the
world the number one dispensary in the
United States let alone in Las Vegas all
right maybe you're hitting Vegas with
your friends your girlfriends whatever
maybe it's a bachelor party whatever's
going on you're going to go watch the
Raiders suck [ __ ] whatever it is make
sure you pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas
tell them I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
them a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview
um so Juice company album come and top
of the Year clothing coming
clothing on the way yep
um anybody else on your album
uh I got money man
great guy great guy good man
big 30.
uh Boosie Badass of course
[ __ ]
and a lot of my upcoming homies for show
and they can see the rest when they
dropped
did money man give you any crypto advice
yeah he trying to put me all type of
money [ __ ] yeah he's a very I mean
there's a reason they call him money man
yeah yeah his money man for sure that's
his name you're able to uh have you
tapped him with uh J stone at all yep I
got a record with Jace though
he's killing it too he killing I love
what he got going on Shout Out J Stone I
just love his like he's just running up
that independent catalog yeah he is I'm
like man I see him he I think the last
time I saw him he was in a uh he was in
the Maybach Maybach off of that
independent rap money on kush yeah
beautiful that's the last time I seen
him he was in one of the [ __ ]
that's his maybe I'm like [ __ ] I'm
gonna get one of these yeah I told him
that now he's working hard though man
it's dope to see man anybody else from
uh from from your area you want a shout
out who's on the come up [ __ ] copy
Supreme all money business
uh Pac-Man
shout out to Pac-Man shout out Pac-Man
uh uh shout out GI Joe Long Live GI Joe
um
[ __ ]
hard who you [ __ ] with Barry
Papa
for show from District
it's a lot of [ __ ] from the district
though that's hard I [ __ ] with Jason I
[ __ ] with the whole Money Ain't Heavy of
course of course I'm with copy like
that's my brother
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [ __ ]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
um give me a crazy boozy story because
he's got [ __ ] the pool parties that
him in trouble were doing during the
pandemic look [ __ ] insane
every time he's on IG live his house is
just so [ __ ] huge
I I love the fact he made his kids walk
his property line when they [ __ ] up
boozy is like the most entertaining
rapper alive so I can only imagine that
you've been in some funny situations
with him can you share something very
funny he said
[ __ ] uh
I'll pull up to his house early morning
or something and he he had come
downstairs that [ __ ] mean in the
morning he had come downstairs all hot
looking
blow his way
he see me and he'll just be also what up
cuz here we are some Cali [ __ ] like he
was like I'm gonna get my Cali on I'm
doing it right yeah what up he be on and
I'll be like look at this [ __ ] man it's
like I got a lot of stories though like
I could I could go next time I interview
him I'm gonna have him do his Cali yeah
yeah you gotta have him do it he do it
cold I'm like yo I need you to I need
Cali Boosie right now
talk to me like you talked to spiffy in
the morning
well the first 10 minutes of the
interview yeah oh that's funny you're
gonna put it on
would you guys do that would you guys do
a joint album for sure
we working on one actually we working on
one so that's gonna happen that's gonna
happen how many records in we probably
bought like six records in
we got a lot of records though but like
as far as ones we gonna use for our
joint project we buy Six records in so I
just don't man well look I can't wait to
hear the album what's it called buried
emotions buried emotions yeah coming top
of the Year top of the Year by the time
you watch this it'll probably be
it's probably going to come out next
Friday
so a couple of weeks away yeah I'm
coming soon and I'm coming soon juice
coming juice coming clothes coming
album with Boosie coming
so much shows coming all kind of [ __ ]
coming bro I'm working
yes you are man well I appreciate you
pulling up hey we're gonna do a
freestyle too you picked a crazy beat so
there'll be a different YouTube video to
go watch that I can't wait to hear what
you got on Hit Em Up by Tupac for sure
time to hit him up I don't live pot
spiffy Luciano bootleg kept podcast